TRAVIS WEBB: Welcome to
Mainframe Modernization,
Accelerating Legacy
Transformation
With Google Cloud.
Hi, I'm Travis Webb, enterprise
solutions architect at Google.
Thanks for joining me at
Google Cloud, next on air.
I work with our customers to
help them solve their biggest,
most complex IT problems.
And today, I'm going to discuss
mainframe modernization,
a new solution
offering from Google.
This is an introductory talk.
So we're going to start out with
an overview of the mainframe
ecosystem.
I'll then discuss
mainframes' place
in our world today
and some common ways
that our customers have
tried, often with bad results,
to migrate off the mainframe.
Next, I'll introduce
Google's offering
for mainframe modernization.
And finally, we'll walk
through one customer's journey
as they migrated thousands
of AS400 and mainframe COBOL
programs to run natively
in Google Cloud.
Let's talk about the
mainframe ecosystem.
First, let me give you a quick
overview of the mainframe
market today.
The mainframe market is large.
It includes the costs of
the machines themselves,
but also the fees paid for
the usage of those machines
and licenses for mainframe
specific software.
The vast majority
of large companies
use mainframes to run
critical business workloads.
And many of those
applications have been built
over the course of decades.
Mainframe usage extends beyond
the very largest companies.
And there are many thousands of
mainframe systems still in use.
And each of these
systems represents
an opportunity for
Google and the customer
to come together to partner
on a strategic transformation
of their business.
As commodity workloads
are moving to the Cloud
at a rapid pace, mainframe
workloads have lagged behind.
Let's talk about some
of the reasons for this.
It's important to
remember that, for most
of the history of computing,
the idea of running
important business processes
on a personal computer
would have you laughed
out of the room.
The PC was a toy.
It was only in this
current Millennium
that doing important things
on individual PCs or servers
was taken seriously.
So how is the
mainframe so resistant
to effective competition?
First, the IBM mainframe
has an unbroken chain
of backward compatibility
going back to the 1960s.
This durability has
allowed the mainframe
to amass a large installed
base of customers
and a reliable revenue
stream for mainframe vendors.
And while the physical
systems from the 1960s
are no longer in use today,
many of the early programs,
written decades ago,
survive to this day.
Second, our IT leaders
have a tendency
to closely scrutinize the
entrance costs when evaluating
a technology
purchasing decision,
while much less attention
is paid to the exit costs.
Leaving the mainframe platform
was expensive and difficult.
And for many businesses,
the cost of migrating still
isn't economically viable.
A proprietary ecosystem
adds to the high exit costs
because many
mainframe applications
rely on proprietary
technologies that
are not available outside
the mainframe ecosystem.
This combination of factors
leaves current mainframe
customers with few
viable alternatives.
If the mainframe vendor
has a large installed base
of customers who can't
leave, why should they
invest in innovation?
While much improvement occurred
throughout the 20th century,
the relative advantages of the
mainframe over other platforms
have eroded over time.
And today, mainframe
customers now
find themselves at a
technological and cost
disadvantage compared
to their peers.
You no longer need a mainframe
to run intensive processing
tasks, but if you
already have one,
you're stuck paying
for it anyway.
The interesting thing here
is that these disadvantages
are widely recognized
and understood.
But mainframe customers
had few viable options
available to assist in
migrating their mainframe
workloads to the Cloud.
With no new customers
or developers
entering the ecosystem,
mainframe vendors
de-emphasized investment
in innovation.
Of course, around Y2K
companies started figuring out
how to use commodity servers to
run business workloads, instead
of mainframes.
Google, of course, was at the
forefront of this movement.
It has pioneered many key
data center infrastructure
innovations.
We serve customers all over
the world with technology
that we've built
into Google Cloud
and at a scale that simply
would never have been possible
with mainframes.
Meanwhile, public Cloud is
democratizing IT innovations
at an incredible pace.
And its explosive growth
comes from companies
looking to leverage
modern technologies
that their legacy
vendors aren't providing.
It's no secret to anyone
that legacy IT is expensive
and mainframe often
tops the list.
But lots of things
are expensive.
And high operating costs
might be tolerable,
if you also got innovation
and agility in return.
But with mainframe, you really
end up with the opposite--
a static ecosystem that
gets more and more expensive
and makes it harder
and harder to innovate.
Customer expectations
are increasing.
The pace of innovation
is increasing.
Yet many mainframe customers
see a chronic shortage
of qualified staff who
understands these technologies,
putting at risk decades of
investment in the platform.
Again, these issues
are widely recognized,
widely understood, most
acutely by mainframe customers
themselves.
And many are
saying, we want out.
Companies have tried
many different approaches
over the years to migrate
off the mainframe platform
and often, never quite
achieve escape velocity.
And they end up
getting pulled back in.
There are three
main ways customers
attempt to modernize these
legacy systems on their own.
You can undertake a
large manual rewrite
of all your mainframe software
into the cool new language
of the week.
You can use an emulator to
run your entire mainframe
environment on normal computers.
Or you can modernize in
place, keeping the mainframe,
but updating the software.
We're going over
these approaches
because they are
all anti-patterns.
And we want to help
customers avoid
these pitfalls in the future.
I've talked to customers in the
middle of a manual rewrite, who
have been modernizing since Y2K.
It's expensive, risky,
and it takes forever.
And if you work
with developers, you
know it's difficult for them
to resist the temptation
to improve things along the way.
This, of course, sets
off a chain reaction
of yet more software and
business process changes,
further prolonging the effort.
Meanwhile, the technology around
you is changing all the time.
The idea of having a clean slate
and a fresh start sounds great.
But unfortunately,
experience shows
that it almost never works.
What about emulating the
mainframe environment?
While you can't achieve
true Cloud scale performance
with a single mainframe,
pound for pound,
it's actually really
good hardware.
Most of the problems lie
in the ecosystem layer
and in the cost structure.
So by emulating your
mainframe software
to run on different
hardware, you're
really throwing away
probably the only good thing
about the system and
keeping all the stuff that's
actually holding you back.
You incurred many
of the same risks
as in other
migration approaches,
but realize few of the benefits.
What about In situ
modernization.
We also see companies try
to modernize in place.
They conclude that their own
software is the primary problem
and needs to be updated.
At the same time, they
attempted to bring
pseudo-Cloud capabilities
to the mainframe.
This doesn't solve any of the
problems that cost or talent
scarcity.
And it still involves
a large manual effort
to update existing software.
It's a very expensive way
to prolong the inevitable.
At Google, we have a
different perspective.
We talk to our customers.
We feel their pain.
And they've been looking
to their Cloud partners
for a way to migrate
these mainframe
workloads to the Cloud.
We've built a
solution called G4.
It combines Google's
considerable engineering
capabilities with decades
of mainframe modernization
experience.
We've developed this expertise
and technology internally,
as well as through
key acquisitions.
What is G4?
The G4 platform is a set of
tools developed and proven
over the last 25 years
that transforms your legacy
mainframe applications to
run natively on Google Cloud,
by converting legacy code to
m based on open standards.
With G4, we've successfully
taken customers from COBOL
to containers in
a matter of weeks.
What was previously too
expensive, too risky,
too difficult, is now
possible at Google scale.
And we believe that this is a
unique offering not available
elsewhere in the market.
Let's talk about G4 for a
minute and go over what it does
and how it works.
G4 consists of three
major components--
the analyzer, the converter,
and the dashboard.
The G4 analyzer parses
your mainframe source code
to understand your
business logic and program
dependencies in relationships.
The G4 converter
applies conversion rules
to your mainframe
code and transforms it
into modern Cloud-native Java.
The converter supports dozens
of mainframe languages,
such as COBOL, PL/1 RPG, GCL,
Assembly, and many others,
and can also help modernize
database business logic, IMS
and VSAM.
The G4 dashboard provides
performance and complexity
metrics about your software
that assists in the testing
and tuning of the applications.
At a high level, our
migration process
follows the tried
and true methodology
that we use for migrating other
mission critical workloads
to Google Cloud.
The insights from
the G4 analyzer
drive the discovery
and assessment phases,
which feed into the G4
converter, which modernizes
legacy mainframe code.
Proper validation,
verification, and testing
ensure that the
business logic operates
as expected and reduces risk.
The G4 analyzer parses and
decomposes your sources
into clusters, which informs
the optimal migration strategy.
G4 then converts the mainframe
sources, cluster by cluster,
and produces target
code in Java that is
optimized to run in the Cloud.
This cluster based strategy
allows the customer
to migrate their
applications in waves,
in parallel as the
migration effort,
using a migration
factory approach.
And I should note here, the code
produced by the G4 converter
is free and clear--
no license, no lock
in, and no nonsense.
Let me summarize some of
the important benefits
that customers can realize.
With G4, you can reduce costs
and risks, while increasing
agility and innovation.
Costs decrease when you escape
the capital intensive mainframe
refresh cycle,
eliminate MIPS charges,
and end reliance on
undifferentiated maintenance
toil, just to keep
the mainframe running.
Business risk is reduced
by ending reliance
on a closed ecosystem
of unsupported software
and a chronic talent shortage.
G4 increases operational
efficiency, agility,
and innovation by extending the
life of mature software assets,
running them on the Cloud, and
leveraging existing investments
in your software.
By gaining access to
modern Cloud technologies,
you can further optimize,
adapt, and evolve your software
in ways that were not
previously feasible.
With some of these
benefits in mind,
I'd like to share with you the
journey of one of our mainframe
modernization customers.
We're working with a large
credit data aggregation
company.
You can think of them
as a credit bureau, who
is anticipating a 5x
increase in customer queries
due to recent changes
in legislation.
Most of their mission
critical applications
are written in COBOL
and running on both
a mainframe and
AS400 style systems.
They're also making use of
other mainframe technologies,
like KIX, JCL,
Easytrieve, and DV2.
Due to the forthcoming
increase in demand,
the customer is
looking to migrate
to a modern, scalable
platform and to modernize
their applications to
support future enhancements.
They had thousands of AS400
and mainframe programs and 12
months to make it happen.
What kinds of workloads
did we migrate?
In mainframe land, there
are two major categories
of workloads, online and batch.
And they have different
architectural requirements.
Online programs process requests
and responses in real time
and record those transactions
in a database, as they happen.
So if I want to transfer
$100 into my bank account,
I want that to happen now.
And that would be an
online transaction.
This is also known as OLTP, or
online transaction processing.
Batch programs
process book data,
often to aggregate records
generated throughout the day
and perform analyses.
As an example a
batch process might
aggregate all trades that
occur in a given trading day
and determine a
bank's risk exposure.
Batch programs are
scheduled using
JCL, job control language.
How did we modernize
JCL batch programs?
Due to the
extensibility of G4, we
can create custom
conversion rules.
In this case, we modernized
the customer's JCL
to run a Cloud Composer, a
managed workflow orchestration
service in Google Cloud
based on Apache Airflow.
These workflows
trigger batch processes
running on Compute Engine
container optimized
VMs inside a managed
instance group.
These batch processes are Java
executables running the Open
JDK runtime environment.
For online workloads, we
deploy the converted mainframe
applications to Compute Engine
inside a managed instance
group.
Because these
workloads are intended
to be accessed by
partners and customers
over the public internet,
we deployed a load balancer
to direct traffic to the VMs.
And we migrated the existing
DB2 database to DB2 LUW
in Compute Engine.
Depending on your
access requirements,
you might instead deploy a VPN
or an interconnect to your data
center for secure communication
within your corporate network.
And depending on your
transaction processing
requirements, we could
deploy DB2 LUW directly
to Google Cloud or
we can re-platform
your relational
database to PostgreSQL
and deploy our Cloud
SQL managed service.
OK, we've covered a pretty wide
range of topics in this talk,
from computing history
to Cloud economics
to mainframe deployment
architectures.
So here are a few
key points I'd like
to highlight before you go.
G4 is a true, end to end,
mainframe migration solution
from Google.
It enables our customers
to reduce costs and risks,
while increasing
agility and innovation.
Proofs of concept are in
high demand by our customers,
due to the potential this has
to transform their business.
And importantly, Google
is the only Cloud provider
with an integrated, end to
end mainframe modernization
solution.
Thank you for joining me today
at Google Cloud, Next On Air.
I look forward to
working with you
on your mainframe
modernization journey.